it's closing time after another long
tough day in a factory making clothes
and shoes for some of the world's
biggest brands Cambodia's garment
industry employs around 800,000 people
and is the driving force behind its
economy but their jobs are under threat
because of a decision by the European
Union which is Cambodia's biggest
customer that could make it 12 percent
more expensive to send products their
workers say they haven't been warned
about the announcement but the prospect
of factories closing or reducing their
hours is worrying it would affect me a
lot because I need all that money to
spend on my family especially for daily
expenses like food my small daughter
needs milk so if this factory closes it
won't be easy to find another job a year
ago the EU signaled that it would end
Cambodia's preferential trade
arrangement that allows most goods to be
sent to Europe
tax-free the announcement came after the
government launched a crackdown on
dissent banning the main opposition
party and charging its leader with
treason among the demands from the EU is
that the case against Kim Sarkar be
dropped and it wants better protection
and rights for workers and factories
according to leaked documents from the
European Commission in Parliament
they're likely to opt for a partial
withdrawal of the agreements rather than
a complete cancellation with one of
their main concerns being job losses in
communities like this the EU may also be
trying to limit geopolitical space for
China which is becoming increasingly
assertive in Southeast Asia according to
a Cambodian government official Chinese
President Xi Jinping urged Cambodia's
Prime Minister Hun Sen not to bow to
European demands when they met in
Beijing last week but China would also
lose if the trade agreement is cancelled
most of the investor are from China
second Cambodia import all the raw
material from China it seems certain the
EU will want to follow through and
punish the Cambodian government to some
extent when the final announcement is
made any changes to the tariff free
trade deal would come into force in six
months which could have a big impact on
hundreds of thousands of Cambodian
workers Wayne hey al Jazeera phenom pen